People like to march to their own beat, and
it turns out, so do cockatoos.
Palm Cockatoos, found in northern Australia
and New Guinea, are large birds that are easily
recognized by their rosy cheeks and giant
head feathers.
But as researchers at Australian National
University found,
they have something that other animals don’t: rhythm.
When male cockatoos want to show off to females,
they grab a stick or a seedpod
and start whacking a hollow tree branch.
This rhythmic tapping is one of the rare examples
of maintaining a beat
found in the animal kingdom.
Animals such as whales and other birds produce
a “song,” but these don’t have the well
defined cadence of the palm cockatoo's drumming.
The use of rudimentary tools to assist in
making music
has only ever been observed in two species.
The Palm Cockatoo, and humans
Not even chimpanzees, humanity’s closest
cousin, use tools to make music.
The analysis of 18 birds and 131 songs revealed
that cockatoos use repeated elements, beat
patterns, and have rhythms unique to each
individual bird.
The cockatoo’s beat may in the future inform
us
as to why cultures developed their own rhythms and dances,
and what possibly came before the first drum
was hit.